se réfugier dans une station
de métro. Les sifflets
des policiers et les sirènes
retentissent aux quatre coinsde.
(coup de sifflet)
Automobilistes et motocyclistes
doivent se garer.
(annonce dans un haut-parleur)
Dans ce sous-sol aménagé
pour la diffusion en direct
à la télé loce e de l'exercice,
des responsables expliquent
à des figurants com
se protéger.
Les citoyens de Taipei
prennent cet exerciceèèèèèèèèèè.
La population a répondu
à l'appel. Regardez cette artère
qui est normalement bondée,erer.
Pendant 30 minutes, lundi,
en ville fantôme. Des exercices
d'd'évacuation en cas d'attaque
aérienne ont lieu dans
le
toute la semaine.
C'est une bonne façon
de se préparer au pire,fefefefee
terrée dans son magasin de
chaussures pendant l'exercice.
Cetomomme, lui, croit
que davantage de citoyens
devraient
anti-bombes du gouvernement
lors de l'exerci
afin de mieux se préparer.
Pendant ce temps, l'armée
taïnanaise donne le coup
d'envoi à sa semaine
d'exercices
(tirs et explosion)
Défense antiaérienne ettetetet.
Taïwan veut lancer le message
à son voisin chinois que
l'île est prête à faire face
qu'elle a retenu les leçons
de la guerre en Ukraine.
La Chine, pour sa part,
multiplie ses incursions
dans l'espace aérien taïwanais
et durcit le ton contre
les États-Unis pour empêcher
la visite à Taipei dedededededee
des représentants, Nancy Pelosi.
"Nous réagirons vivement
si une telle visite a lieu,l.lÉs
devraient en subir
les conséquences."
Alors, risques réels de guerre
Probablement pas,
lolon cette spécialiste.
VALÉRIE NIQUET, auteure,
"Taïwan face à- - - - - - - - -e
a rencontrées en Ukraine,
même si elle s'imposent
au Donbass, eh bien,
ont déaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiï,
contrôler Taïwan, tenir Taïwan,
eh bien, c'est une opération qui
serait extrêmement difficile.
(explosion)
- Taïwan multiplie malgré tout
les exercices de préparation
de tous genres ces dernières
semaines. De nombreux citoyens
se préparent aussi au pire.
Ici Philie e Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Taipei.